What was once a race thing isn't a race thing anymore.
It's a need for La to be more developed for everyone.
I'm Dominique.
I am 27 and I'm a realtor in La.
Uh,
my name is Florida's.
I'm 20 years old and I am a student.
I'm Rob,
I'm 27 and I'm a writer.
Uh,
my name is Terrance.
I'm 26 transplant and I work currently for security at Lex.
I'm Dominique,
right?
I'm 32 and uh,
I don't know what my employees beside the sea,
so I can't really tell you about that.
Can I get my la logos on the left and my la traffic fines on the right
the first day?
Yeah.
People have the right to live.
Where are they choose
and like the purest,
most distilled form of that question.
Yeah,
I would definitely agree that if you are able to live somewhere in you,
you know,
are willing to live there and not just,
cause I think there's a difference between occupying
okay.
And actually being a participant,
Katie,
exactly what to contribute to really live there.
It's probably freedom of speech.
You can say whatever you want,
but there are negative connotations that could happen from you saying something
just as if you move somewhere there could possibly be damaging effects even
though you have no ill intent at all.
Something could happen where you moved in here.
All your homies and friends moves there and everyone's here now and then the
people were there first.
Can't even go.
I think what I perceived in that question was just like your absolute mobility
and moving like where ever you want without like the repercussions of like for
say you're moving into this space that has a lot of history and your presence is
like,
could peep,
could I possibly oppressive to the preexisting communities?
I enjoy returning to the place where I am.
Hello?
Okay.
I wasn't sure because I still live in the place I grew up.
So
my hometown is in Massachusetts,
which is very different from Los Angeles.
And he said,
I miss some of the seasonal things about it for sure.
Yeah.
We don't have seasons here.
You never get,
um,
winters are falls like we do out there.
The town where I grew up,
my parents only live chose that place because the taxes were really high there,
but it all went to like the good school systems.
When my sister and I left,
they sold the house and I know it's hard for my sister
because we can't really go back home and that sense I'd say living in Echo Park
my whole life
while I'm living there,
I see it changing right before my eyes.
And it's this like weird,
weird experience where you see the people you grew up with saying,
oh,
I can't afford this rent,
I'm,
I have to move over like 30 miles away.
And I think that's one major thing that gentrification does and that's,
it really makes people lose their sense of like belonging and community building
and top route people.
Yeah,
me being nomadic in nature.
I'm a military kid.
I've grown up in so many different places.
It's not where I grew up,
it's who was there.
Most of the family has moved and most of my friends have moved away from where I
grew up in Michigan.
Also.
I kind of grew up in a very bad neighborhood.
It wasn't the greatest.
The high school I you went to wasn't the greatest.
So,
um,
it's hard when I go back there and then I'll see those things.
I'm reminded of how I grew up.
I totally hear that.
And um,
being from central Pennsylvania and I never really feel,
felt like I belonged there from when I was very young.
You know,
I feel like Pennsylvania made me,
but la really made me,
you know,
like I'm from there,
but I feel like this is where I became who I am.
Things about the city that I love.
Like I would not want to die anywhere else,
but there is so many things that have changed in the city.
So just imagine being 30 and seeing people that you grew up with,
not being able to afford a apartment on a street where the rent shouldn't be no
more than $1,200.
I guess.
I haven't been away for a long period of time to say I miss it just because I'm
just in it.
Every since
go
is more important than its economic status.
I'm a rock.
What?
Yeah,
I think it is.
I'm journey.
The Almighty dollar has a rice start history and we have to,
we have to preserve it.
Are we going to just repeat the same
exactly.
We learned from history.
Exactly.
So how are we going to move forward in a society if we don't recognize exactly.
You know,
you see like a city like Detroit,
right,
where not his city has so much history,
especially with the u s as economy took a city that was so bustling to somewhere
where there are many parts of the cities that I hear like no man's land with,
with reinvigoration I think also comes job opportunities.
You know,
it keeps the community that like up and moving and bustling.
I you just have to find your space.
I grew up in Michigan,
it's like our family from Detroit.
Like that's real.
Like Motown is like my,
that's my rule.
It's like they still have like museums there that are set up the Fox theater.
Like I still remember going there as a kid.
Like it's,
it's amazing like being there like in so crazy.
So how would you feel
they tore it down though?
It'd be like someone taking a piece of my heart and just like put it on the
floor.
Like for real,
they're trying to tear down the current sale ma and make it to be like the
growth,
which I think is,
you don't need another terrible idea just because of the people that aren't
living in that,
that area.
They're not going to be able to afford it.
Luxury lofts cater to the preexisting community rights.
I have to say I have to disagree.
I actually work a lot in that area.
So I work with people who flipped houses and I think it depends who's who in
that area your speaking to.
Because you know,
I meet a lot of the owners in that area and for them they're loving it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ours
are not and you know,
but also some renters because now it's becoming more walkable.
What was once a racing isn't a race thing anymore.
It's a need for La to be more developed for,
for everyone.
Everyone deserves a place to fall.
Uh,
I get the pants.
I don't think you need it deserve for sure.
Every child growing up to an adult to serves task,
something called home.
But for me home is here.
It's not like down the block on 31st it's just like where I'm at,
that's home.
Some people want to move around or don't mind it or if I actually take something
good from it,
but other people are very comfortable in where they are.
I think I can be a state of mind,
a state of being.
I think home absolutely has a feeling more than a location and I think it's
something that evolves to a different stages of life as I have moved from one
and then kind of found one again when I went to college and now I'm just sort of
wondering like I'm realizing I have to build it.
You know?
I think that the word deserve is,
is,
is tough because you know,
I think that people deserve what they create for themselves.
There are some people who were just dealt a bad hand,
you know,
and,
and that,
that is not included in this.
If you're not putting in as much work as I am,
why don't you deserve the same thing that I have?
Unfortunately a lot of people don't have the same knowledge are the same empathy
you might have.
So not saying it's your job or at your duty,
but sometimes because that person may not have that knowledge,
what you might tell them might be able to beat the spark to change their
mentality so they can go out there and do what you should.
Just what they deserve to have something where you feel like you don't have
anything.
You know,
most of the time you either are going to do something bad or you an archer.
So
see some people take that and they use that to become something even bigger and
better and that's,
you know what I mean?
A lot of people don't know how to do that.
I mean,
if someone's parent doesn't teach them those things,
why is it then your responsibility to pick up for the parents?
Yes.
This is more of a moral,
yeah.
Well here's my thing.
Like I feel like home looks so different to everybody,
right?
How does someone else having a home really affect mine at all?
Like,
like I'm trying to think about like,
people would just need the basic necessities.
Like I'm not saying every person needs a four floor high rise.
Like I think that it's possible that everyone has some sort of home
instabilities,
some kind of starting point,
and then everyone else can go up from there.
I don't see why there should be an issue about someone's struggling just to live
in their own place.
Like I don't,
I don't,
I'm not making that correlation.
And I don't know,
maybe that's just me and I might not be as diverse in economic and housing
market as you,
but I don't see why every single person should not be able to be inside
somewhere.
I think we as a whole have gotten away from empathy and have latched on to
apathy cause it's easy to say,
well I did it so you can do it.
No,
but,
and I knew that people do have different situations and they come with different
weights on their shoulders and whatnot.
But I also,
I think that really the issue that everybody's kind of touching on is that
everyone deserves education.
Everyone deserves to know what they can do and how they can arm themselves to,
to be able to,
you know,
be,
have a home and to create more.
I think that it's important for people to take responsibility for the direction
that their life takes.
You know,
once you decide to do that and it stops,
it stops being about what's happening to you.
And instead what you're doing,
you know,
she can change everything for you.
We have to be mindful that apathy is roaming the streets right now and it's
ready to kill everybody and we have to get it away from us and make sure that we
put goodness and kindness in our heart and we're able to express that and give
to others.
Yes.
Hey guys,
this is John from jubilee.
Thanks for watching this episode of middle ground.
Uh,
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments below and also what other topics
you'd like to see in an episode of middle ground.
Please be sure to click subscribe and remember to live greater.